in Vietnam a massive percentage of
people tried heroin the U.S government
thought they were going to have this
epidemic of heroin addicted soldiers
when they got back but that's not what
happened why when people get on heroin
in the U.S and then they go to a rehab
center nine out of ten of them relapsed
back into taking heroin so what is the
difference it's because the environment
changed if you are a heroin addict in
this environment and then you change
your environment to a rehab center then
all of a sudden you're not a heroin
addict in that environment you don't
have the cues you don't have the access
you don't have the resources Etc and
then you go back into the place you have
the same access the same resources Etc
then it cues the same behaviors now the
soldiers had environments but they were
one-time environments and when they came
back to the US they lost all of those
cues and all those rewards associated
with why they were doing her to begin
with because they changed their
environment they changed their behavior